[Music]
hello everybody welcome to honest
trailer commentaries we're here to break
down the honest trailer for ghost in the
show yes not the good one the one
starring Scarlett Johansson yay well we
just released the trailer on our YouTube
channel and here as the show which we've
been doing on our Plus channel but now
everyone here to break down sort of our
thoughts in the film and someone we have
some outtakes yes of jokes that didn't
make it in which you'll be able to see
at the end of this trailer commentary as
well as discuss it let's get right to it
Joestar haha happy to be here talking
about this terrible movie Spencer
Gilbert here just realizing the Jo
wasn't wearing the Hat ironically over
the weekend he's really committing to
the Hat yeah it's a good hat it's a
Yojimbo hat yeah you saw huge Jimbo hat
yeah yes it's an old comic book Spencer
I'm aware yeah you thought the comic-con
would have brought us together
Joe made Spencer to a whole random tiny
wiener I mean I think on flick bait I
think all bombers lower back tattoo so
we'll never be completely on the same
page I told me was right thank you
let's talk about this movie though
because this movie's not right right
visually it's cool can we give it let's
go positive there's some cool visuals it
looks great it's it's but it's very it's
not it's it's kind of it's fun but it's
not because it it looks very derivative
of other sci-fi movies I get that goes
in shale inspired a lot of sci-fi movies
so you can't totally fault that but when
I was watching it I'm like yeah but you
you still made it look like Blade Runner
a little yeah the original does that
look like Blade Runner like the city
doesn't look like that it looks right so
it's 50/50 it's like part of it is it's
just naturally gonna feel like that cuz
other movies took from it and part of it
is like I really don't think they did a
lot to make it feel different wait did
they take the Blade Runner to bleep know
that Blade Runner is before guys
this movie from not I'd get those things
in this movie they're gonna be like
matrix cuz this movie inspired the
matrix so heavily however that doesn't
mean then why did this movie seem to
take things for Blade Runner it still
felt very generic sci-fi maybe into in
places where it wasn't forced to be
students are you look confused yeah I'm
a little confused yeah this movie it
just looked like Tokyo today or just an
Asian city was just plus Holograms so I
thought that there was really cool
imagery in the trailers at least but I
don't know that the movies so boring the
movie has nothing outside of Scarlett
Johansson's monotone character crisis
there's nothing to like get invested in
it's really just like a series of kind
of cool images and then it ends yeah
it's short
- it's like a 90 minute movie which hey
that's a positive I guess they just
didn't have much story to tell except
the barest bone summary of the anime so
yeah okay next anything else to add
before we play this thing and watch it
through mm-hmm really no I apologize for
making fun of Joe's hat I did honest
pros yeah yeah no it's the riffs gone
come on yeah what is the bad yeah just
confuse back oh I don't like him yeah
yeah I'll give you a high five yeah I
had that action but I it was handed to
me by the man who created the character
now don't you feel like a dick yeah Bret
rewind
I can't wait tell them how their
favorite special regret moment is you
against Seth Rogen trying to argue
[Applause]
in the dancing this is what we typically
do here we watch the trailer and
applause and stop it's like a reaction
video so many people react to these
videos already went up like snow white
in the hoods with and transformers to be
thrilled in the span for right and Ono's
comes the glossy hollywood adaptation of
a book workups does they make money yeah
the director again made some money it's
a vision big visual movie so he has the
expertise in that but yeah I mean when
they're successful
sadly they may transcend the writer that
were referencing with the turns towards
two three or four when you look at his
filmography that I don't get cuz it's
like over like 15 years and like garbage
garbage garbage garbage garbage that was
okay garbage garbage like why are you
still getting hired because playing the
politics he's probably a good guess man
I wasn't sure that's the right movies
for the critics man for the fans for the
fans he's probably really charismatic
and like you meet him like I love that
guy hands over like a script written in
crayon
we're getting really shooting okay
workday's
yeah he's never coming on the show all
right let's go comes the gloss not
Hollywood adaptation of a beloved
Japanese anime that goes about as well
as you'd expect girls not a show
Hollywood is running out of stuff from
the 80s and 90s to rematch now they're
remaking the film
they've already been ripping off for
decades but with controversial casting a
dumbed-down plot new shoes used to do
penuche coos just enough recreated
scenes from the anime to put it in the
trailers and a complete lack of
understanding about what made the
franchise popular to begin with because
as Dragonball Evolution taught American
film executives if at first you don't
succeed blame the reviews and learn
nothing from your mistakes that we
almost stepped into with with the
potential misunderstanding of our point
on that yeah yeah because we were gonna
call out more than just Dragonball Z we
had Astro Boy and Speed Racer but we
realized that Speed Racer and we just
meant critically commercially successful
and that was a nuance that would of
course get lost it's called the Megamind
dilemma where people like and in the
context of like we were just saying the
Mega Man we didn't think people remember
very much and we were very much moving
wrong on that people didn't see it not
you person who saw Megamind you saw it
but people is a billion dollar hey I
like this one because I actually do like
Speed Racer a lot remember Astro Boy we
might have no keep that one in Speed
Racer was a flag me liked we want the
mega mine on this cuz I think we'll get
it yeah and we did pull it the point we
were trying to make was that Speed Racer
was and it was an adaptation that was
not successful and that many people
the studio just kind of moved on from it
didn't really change anything about
marketing or bad release and Yeah right
after Ironman there was we didn't feel
like the subtlety got through and we
didn't want all of the comment to
deposit on our shop comparison with the
anime but people keep saying oh this is
such a beautiful movie though and it's
like look at the comparative in the
original movie is set in
post-apocalyptic Japan it's a
post-apocalyptic city and it's still so
much brighter this whole movie is so
dark it's like I can't even tell that
the spider tank is in yeah it's true
that middle frame like the it's a very
dark movie yeah it's just like you can't
yeah I think it's ever daytime except
that one scene in the fountain yeah and
when she goes to visit her agent mom get
to that yeah that's true CGI is much
cheaper in the dirt that's it anyway
let's get here you've seen Scarlett
Johansson as a Special Ops soldier and
enhanced human a stoic outsider a sexy
robot voice you feel me with uranium and
a white girl feeling out of place in
Asia
now she'll combine them all as the major
and enhanced Special Ops sexy robot boy
stoic outsider white girl who feels out
of place in Asia I don't know her to
trust anymore
she's a Robocop with a weird Robo walk
so weird had only one weakness we're
getting snuck up on by dudes with Tasers
happening in electric watch is the
studio avoids a whitewashing controversy
by showing off how multicultural their
version of Hong Kong is and explaining
that majors body is just the robot shelf
or someone else's brain you made you a
new body a synthetic shell no ghost
which all right I'll bite then cringe
and disbelieve as the studio manages to
ruin their own solution by revealing
that yep she was full-blown Japanese all
along what's your name you just try to
put out a dumpster fire with a much
larger easily avoidable dumpster fire I
mean ever wants to be stones or hands
yes but I think that they had a solution
which was her brain came from parents
and they even mentioned her parents like
died on a boat over to this country
she's like okay so they she's an
immigrant cyborg yeah culture was very
vague and that really brought up and
it's like hey they just took the brain
and put in the body okay like we said
when they wanted someone to go to the
Hong Kong for did we send something to
Hong Kong or Tokyo for this I can't
remember we sent uh Mari and she was
like I don't love it but I'll buy it and
it's like okay you pulled it off you
figured it out they're like no the brain
is a Japanese aliy to be fair I have
seen in the comments a little bit of it
it's actually starting a discussion
which is great by the way I love that
people are actually having a discussion
about this and sort of politely kind of
a polite discussion part of the movie is
about the cultural disconnect of being a
Japanese person in a cyborgs body like I
didn't pick up those things from the
movie myself for me it was very much
more of just like I spent a lot of the
movie going like you know what they kind
of sidestep this nicely and constructed
the world to kind of get rid of this
controversy the original is a really
Japanese story because it's like a
post-apocalyptic Japan I'm pretty sure
it's Japan and they're like it's all
about we have we retained our soul or
have we given into like commercialism
and like corporations and
like handed over our humanity so which
is like a post-war Japan in like the 80s
and 90s yeah so yeah they what they want
their cake and they want to eat it too
so they wanted their cake and then they
wanted to put that cake into a body a
robotic body and then yeah it looked
like Scarlett Johansson I wasn't I mean
watching it again I wasn't necessarily I
wouldn't say I was offended by it but it
was really more of just like I haven't
seen my head was like wow movie like I
was kind of giving you points for how
definitely you maneuvered around that
controversy and then I'm not saying it's
right or wrong sure but then you just
dropped yourself even deeper into that
vat of just like making a controversial
again it's like that just seemed like an
unforced and the thing of it is is
because this movie just sort of feels
shallow like we said you know it's like
they don't really how interesting would
it have been if they had really leaned
into that like no you were instead of
just making that a silly dumb revealed
like Easter Egg no it's the character's
name from the original at the end if
they had really leaned into yeah you're
now a Japanese lady in this white robot
body like every little even more like an
outsider and like more connects with
their family and stuff like that yeah
they could have if they'd gone that way
again it's like okay well you did that
but then you made that at a very complex
issue in the movie but they didn't it
was just like oh it's a reveal by the
way we didn't even mention Michael Pitt
also Japanese so actually to to Japanese
people in the robot body yeah but yeah I
know I agree like I feel like they
wanted to go down a weird road with that
but they didn't really so it was just
kind of this weird disconnected like
what ya know it seemed very kind of
tone-deaf to what had they knew the
controversy with scarves or Hansen
existed anyway and it seemed weird of
like least ISTEP but then go back into
yeah lean into it show us more
flashbacks and like actually make those
two sort of like parallel threads and
went the wasted opportunity I would have
been an interesting movie though yes how
dare you how dare you not give me that
Transformers to writer much larger
easily avoidable dumpster fire
Jackie and as the major teams up with
side characters who get two to four
lines of dialogue they're annoying and
by Japanese legend beat Takeshi who was
smart enough to know this movie wasn't
worth speaking English for so many think
is gone you still fish you figure not
good or do Donald together they'll chase
down an evil Max Headroom hacker can you
see your boobs or not I can't tell and I
definitely care what else is going on
movies really boring so gear up for the
latest movie with John Carter syndrome
where the source material was so
influential that now it feels like it's
copying the films that inspired and
witnessed the newest lame attempt at a
live-action anime film which we should
really just leave to the Japanese at
this point the full metal movie looks
horrible - it's good I hope so and
Spencer review Japanese anime movies
yeah that sounds like a fun bit flick
bait yeah or just a real review alright
we're gonna do something we've
whitewashed our own reviewing staff good
titles by Robert yeah Japanese oh yes a
big Japanese I really think so cable
beat Takeshi beat beat Takeshi Palpatine
keep honest in the back I just want to
point out that because I've been binging
it lately is that beat Takeshi is on my
favorite TV show of all time the most
extreme elimination challenge
have you seen that there's full episodes
on YouTube so watch that and it's just
over dubbed Japanese as a while ago no
he's the announcer guy yet I don't know
who the American counterpart to him
would be because he's like directed a
million films he's a legit movie star
over there but then he also like hosts
that game shows and the original I think
it's called takeshi's castle and the
obstacle course is apparently to just
get inside his house these weird like
side businesses that he does
infomercials for I check him out he's a
game show so much better better yes
every just trying to think who is the
current day beat Takeshi would be I
don't know or even counterpoint I don't
I don't know I don't know say in the
comments below the Takeshi Palpatine
business in the front party in the back
boy crap is that top dollar and literal
whitewashing very Westboro Bicentennial
woman cyber mech liver I've been saving
up for a while now it's lost cool every
night uh guys your friend is an
alcoholic that's something we didn't
really attract man yes dancing pac-man
yeah is how like all the cybernetic
augments to really mess you up and
malfunction all the time yeah it's
terrible idea and his eyes are like
these they look terrible looks infected
everyone's getting hacked all the time
but everyone's like yeah yeah do that we
did never improve and I did lost some of
the dialogue that get written into this
movie he's just like you can't do an
unprotected dive into that corrupted
geisha I'm like wow that is a weird
world that we live
this is a movie that's happening right
now
you got a virus from a corrupted geisha
from the original did that in college
ones I was gonna give a shout out to TJ
for editing this because we were done so
yeah we have swapped X I think of
alternate Joe gets the rear according
cuz yeah you know for all the gadgets
maybe invest in a rear camera I mean
even my epic minivan has one of those
turns out to be a rebel fighting the
real bad guys the company that's
pretending to be good oh man you might
not think this movie's offensive but
it's definitely offensively boring story
John yeah Bionic Commando baymax like a
man robot Cable Guy to the lady giving
top billing to the lady who speaks
against the fish so more Japanese actors
would be featured in the cat
discriminator West washed the widest
boards you know that's what he depended
on yeah we did all right
that didn't make it the yeah that last
one that uh the the wall of text was uh
what's-her-name rila something she's in
like all the arrow shows and all that
they made such a huge deal after they
announced Scarlett Johansson as the
major like all the trades were like
guess who else joined the cast and
they're unknown role unknown role and
then it ended up she was just like the
most silent geisha yeah yeah they just
like used her face to base the geisha on
and it's like it was such like a damage
control thing after they announced
Carlin but yeah that wall of text did
not work good trades of the honest
trailer else you got on this one guys
[Music]
sounds like yeah this was a weird one
that movie is a weird choice to make we
did it in between like comic-con we're
still catching up on but I'm glad we got
it out and good work team and thanks to
you all for watching we back next week
with another honest trailer commentary
have a great one bye bye a bull guy